p
bonjour bienvenue pour cette leçon dont
jean baptiste
bonjour stéphane alors qu'est ce qu'on
va voir où l'on lui eh bien on a prévu
de regarder ensemble une défense qu'on
voit de plus en plus haut niveau qui est
la dépense petrov alors défense petro
défense russe n'allait donnant l oms
petrov c'est le joueur qui sait ça et
russes parce que c'est très employée par
les russes alors l'origine du raid je
sais pas trop hein
le monde parce que cette variante a été
inventée là bas ou en tout cas à
développer un art avoir jamais de mots
mais en tout cas un des grands thèmes du
match car pauvre kasparov cette défense
russe
il y en a eu oui mais quelques-unes la
maintenance direct dans les championnats
du monde actuel si vous regardez c'est
peut-être un quart des parties 1 - 1 ap
3 fin parce que c'est une grande grande
barrière grande ouverture
voilà c'est une ouverture qui a la
réputation d'être très solide et très
amusante
voilà vous verrez pas beaucoup de gamins
noirs haut niveau en tout cas bien sûr
avec la défense plus alors très soul
très amusante
essentiellement parce qu'il est
symétrique pascal est symétrique et que
davantage sur la grande ligne se joue a
vraiment des détails alors nous ce qu'on
va voir aujourd'hui justement c'est
comment briser cette symétrie alors on
va regarder une autre variante
aujourd'hui que qui brille cette
asymétrie voile à bord on va regarder
c'est bien qu'ils aient une variante qui
a été popularisé parce qu'à un moment
donné les grands maîtres qui jouent eux
quatre on avait marre aussi de recevoir
des pétroles dans les pneus et
savais pas trop quoi faire pour prendre
avantage ensuite en essayer autre chose
pour pour casser la symétrie et pour
avoir des perspectives d' attaque dans
une variante près seulement il n'y en a
pas alors on y va tout de suite
voilà c'est cette intrigante défense
russe défense petrov alors eu quatre
coups classiques à l'ouverture
c'est le coup de l'initiale de 7,2 cette
ouverture aux 5 à la symétrie à l'envers
là la position de la petrov cavaliers 3
et la cale et silva l'acela pétrole
voilà l'un défend paul sur le 5
on est en fait on a sur la contre
attaque immédiate sur le plan aux quatre
donc symétrie parfaite cavaliers ainsi
qu'amélie la dope y ont attaqué alors
évidemment il ya déjà des grands pièges
aussi sur cette ouverture manquer dans
la ville a ajouté je connus alors
évidemment si elle est 3e 5
mais c'est bien connu mais il faut
vraiment le montrer parce qu'alors si
vous êtes débutant sûr il faut
absolument vous connaissez ce piège qui
va vous rapporter un nombre de points
comme en salle ça c'est sûr disons que
contre vos amis au pub ça va vous
rapporter des points voilà dans la
pratique de la compétition soit qu'on ne
trouve pas mais c'est un piège il faut
connaître ça peut arriver quand même ça
peut faire ça se fera rare mais si on
avait joué semi-rapide contre un joueur
à 1600 1700 on peut trouver l'erreur
dehors peut arriver toutes façons à
n'importe quel moment ça c'est sûr il
faut savoir la gérer donc avalé prend
1,5 et si les noirs joue cavalier
prendre 4 c'est une faute c'est une
faute ouais c'est une faute qui perd du
matériel
pourtant c'est équilibré toujours
puisque c'est symétrique et oui mais les
avantages du trait quand on ouvre la
colonne soit le roi en tête du trait et
décisif pour le cran qui la voile a
alors l'idée c'est simple ces dames de
tout simplement alors c'est quoi l'idée
j'attaque le cavalier et on voit bien
que derrière le cavalier blanc il va y
avoir le roi et si les noirs évidemment
joué le coup simitri dames 7
ça marche pas puisqu'une fois que j'ai
pris cavalier blanc on va le montrer
tout de suite dams est d'en prendre
quatre évidemment les noirs ne peuvent
pas répondre par d'entendre cavaliers
permet d'apparaître là ils perdraient
dans la main voilà alors ils peuvent
encore récupéré le cavalier en jouant
des 6 mai après des cas tout simplement
les blancs ont gagné en groupe y ont un
gros pion central un proprio centrale on
va reprendre le cavalier ou 5 avec un
pion et on a un groupe russe en train
d'avancer un avantage clair net et sans
bavure j'ai envie de dire les noirs vont
se battre
daniela que la nulle dans le meilleur
des cas et souvent ils vont perdre donc
alors cavaliers cavaliers prend dames 2
hélas alors si les noirs je sais c'est
de retirer le cavalier le coup logique
de se dire bon mais sinon je peux
retirer le cavalier tout simplement mail
en ce cas là c'est la catastrophe
absolue puisqu'il ya le catastrophe
cavalli c6 surprenant au premier abord
quand on est débutant mais il ya les
fameux échec et j'ai découvert la
découverte et la dame des huit se
retrouvent attaquer et ne peut même pas
défendre les chèques en venant recettes
et voilà parce que le cab a laissé six
attaques la dame des 8 et protège la
case de cette même dame 7 ne permettrait
pas de sauver la dame
donc il faut jouer fou 7 par exemple ou
d'avant cet écart va les prendre mais
c'est terminé pour la terminer voilà
donc alors cavaliers prend 1,5
on vient de voir la grosse faute à ne
pas commettre qui veut reprendre le
cadre il faut donc jouer le coup
intermédiaire des 6 et 6 voilà qui de
coups qu'on trouve le plus souvent qui
est normal on chasse d'abord le cavalier
on chasse que cavani qui est obligé il
n'y a pas de meilleur coup de revenir à
moins à moins à moins qu'on soit
d'humeur extrêmement sanguinaire
sanguinaire voilà et qu'on joue cavalier
prendre sept voiles alors c'est pas
sépare encore aujourd'hui on va juste un
petit coup d'oeil dessus puisque on
regarde aujourd'hui des variantes un peu
je dirais à l'abandon tomanek ce qui
permet de casser cette symétrie il ya le
grand sacrifice qu'il faut quand même
reconnaître un peu sur la survie des
caries premier set
voilà tout à fait pour qu'elle prend 1,7
alors un coût qui est vraiment
surprenant mais qu'on peut même
considérer comme correcte les parties
par correspondance qui ont été joués
j'étais jouer sur ce thème la montre
démontre que les blancs finalement on
des partis qui sont vraiment jouable
mais à noter aussi investi tout
simplement topalov a fait match nul avec
kramnik sur les sept variantes ouais il
a failli peut-être même le match je sais
pas en fin de chronique a réussi à tenir
le nul alors que elle est réputée comme
la prouve quand même que ma liste les
costauds que ses variantes qui est
vraiment bien donc c'est intéressant ce
roi prend cavaliers l'idée simple on
peut jouer simplement des cas voilà des
4 sachant que la prise du plus haut rang
à quatre n'est pas possible de cavaliers
à cause de damas chuck et il n'y a déjà
plus de bonnes réponses sur geci songer
aussi sam des cinq échecs on récupère le
cavalier
suroît g8 damascène que c'est matt
apprenant fou sur un coup comme moi on
sait tout droit 8 tout simplement vous
dames 2 et cavaliers 4o coups et on va
butter pas possible mais sur 300 euros
seulement on joue des mots nous voilà
donc avec un désastre tout simplement
excellent donc évidemment dame eu deux
dessins f3 on récupère la pièce avec un
gros avantage le roi complètement des
rockets et ses textes heures voilà donc
sur des quatre évidemment les noirs ne
prennent pas le plus henri iv ils vont
devoir maintenant qu'on passe c'est
compensé par dans leur retard de
développement
donc ils vont jouer comme fawcett pour
faire un rogue artificielle bien sûr ils
veulent jouer avec fawcett ils veulent
jouer touré fuite est ensuite vite
mettre le roi à l'abri voilà simplement
et dans ce cas là les blancs maintenant
joue le coup après fou il faut 7 des 4
après il faut 7 voilà maintenant les
blancs et vitamines en cette variante et
joue tout de suite fous ces quatre gta
iv reichshoffen en quatre des cinq
évidemment peut prendre des 5 avec
encore en plus a fait trois pions pour
la pièce c'est beaucoup un coup comme
fou aussi ce quasiment forcé et là on
peut jouer le coup des simples tout
simplement gagne du temps oui alors des
cinq cela conforte le fou noir à
repartir de sa case et donc on ouvre à
nouveau la de la diagonale c4 f7 voilà
alors provisoirement les noirs nous
attaquent la dame dont joue f3 battant
et maintenant on essaie d'ouvrir avec
fracas la dague la tv nal c4 a fait en
outre 5 l'incitant le plan des six a
quitté sa case pour ouvrir la diagonale
ces quatre lettres sur pions prend
évidemment joue ici
voilà des six avec échec
on récupère la pièce avec bénéfice t1
bénéfice au niveau déjà de la structure
de pions c'est sur elle que le pian 2 5
isolé commission qui zone est aussi avec
peut-être le roi noir qui sera des
rockets voilà donc c'est vraiment
intéressant à connaître faut pas se
tromper dans l'ordre évidemment eu cinq
ou six attaques lecavalier 6 et dès que
le cil cavalli bouge on joue tout
simplement aux six échecs il ya plus de
rock artificiel va falloir remettre le
roy on sait pas trop où d'ailleurs
compliqué ça devient extrêmement
difficile pour les noirs et apprendre
envisagé petit rock f4 f5 et c'est donc
évidemment les noirs sur un jeu plus
précis peuvent s'en sortir c'est pas
mais
une variante intéressante qu'il faut
qu'il faut creuser et qui qui est tout à
fait jouable bien sûr mais ça donne qui
a seulement appris faut pas se tromper
dans l' attaque puisque sinon les noirs
s'ils prennent l'initiative après savait
difficile
donc on revient sur calais pour cinq des
six donc on vient de voir ses ventes
marginales on va voir maintenant une
vente plus plus générale avec le coup
simple cavalière trois griefs trois
relations si on remet le cavaliere f3
donc maintenant les noirs ont le droit
de récupérer leur temps aux quatre bien
sûr voilà il n'y a plus de problème sur
dam 2 11 m de 7 alors son dame de
maintenant on peut jouer dans le set et
la dame aux thèses le caméo à l'âtre pas
de problème donc d'un jeu de est pas un
bon coup puisque sa bouche le
développement du fouet fin donc en
général ici il ya deux grands coups en
fait alors soit le coût qui n'est pas
l'objet de cette leçon l'objet d'une
autre leçon une autre fois soit le coût
des quatre voilà sur quoi les noirs et
pondent des 5 et maintenant on commence
à avoir une idée plus précise de la
raison pour laquelle ces deux variantes
à la réputation d'être solide et a dû
lente parce que c'est une symétrie cpt
quasi parfaite si mirek voilà exactement
symétrie parfaite qui est pas facile à
briser autant le dire et qui est très
subtil voilà c'est vrai dans avoir
rappelé les ficelles un autre jour notre
jour parce que c'est une citrine et
c'est très long évidemment c'est une
variante disons aujourd'hui on sait on a
en a choisi de présenter une variante
un peu plus original dix ans où les
blancs pour essayer de trouver du jeu
contre la petrov et comment on fait pour
toi et du jeu la plupart du temps au
brésil 6 mi temps en faisant des rocs
opposés à la paire composée là c'est à
dire que même une position où il n'y a
pas de faiblesse
il n'ya pas se relâcher les noirs et
bien on peut essayer quand même de la
combattre en faisant des rocs opposé en
lançant les pions sur l'europe
reuters donc cavalier ces trois
cavaliers ces trois n'avaient rien la
roma on à en voir un peu loin des ragots
opposé mais disons que on va se
rapprocher vous allez voir alors là il
faut prendre ces trois les autres
tentatives n'ont pas été forcément
toujours une réussite alors des 5 par
exemple perdrait du matériel je pense
après dames 2 dans me2 tout simplement
là me donne pour jouer dans le set était
allé prendre et ça et là dans ce cas là
le twr pionner 5 est en prise la tuile
voilà donc ça serait ce serait une
erreur dont dame 2 pose un problème le
cavalier des clous et ouais et sur un
coup quand même 5 e siècle plus des 3
gagne une pièce d'un mètre
l'alternative donc l'alternative sur
cavalli c3 et c2 ou cavaliers m6 pour
retomber un petit peu dans un d'un
système d'un système de symétrie bien
sûr voilà c'est un coup qu'on trouve
très rarement et quand même faut le dire
un petit peu bizarre
oui c'est mieux de gagner le temps en
france et trois ans récupère ian cook
est très amusant c'est fou au f5 au f5
qui est une gaffe monumentale à puisque
on perd une pièce à cause de dames 2
toujours pareil dame l'ouverture dames 7
urech kawaï et des cinq dames cette
cabale et des 5 avec alors tout à fait
la menace sur le pion c7 qui fait une
fourchette tour dames dont qui oblige la
dame à revenir en 17 au long des huit
voies l'arrivée des trois gagnerait la
pièce si ensuite d2 d3 et le cavalier ou
quatre on voit ici serait cloué
évidemment sur le roi il pourrait pas
bouger donc s'attendre ghanmi rs5 est
une énorme gaffe qui a été joué stéphane
parent qui est bien par je ne sais pas
par un nom de lui-même
ah oui par le jeune attendant il ya
quelques années le jeune allemande avait
quand même 2560 pas rien oui eh bien
j'ai trouvé cette partie dans la base il
a perdu la partie en six coups avait
l'accord contre le grand maître zapata
le grand maître mexicain rafa
l'appareil appartient si coup c'est
assez étonnant quand on connaissait pas
ce pillage en fait un jour sans on
disait tout à l'heure que les pièges
qu'on n'arrive jamais ça arrive un an de
faut les connaître un champion du monde
actuel a réussi un jour à perdre une
partie en six coups alors qu'il était
déjà un grand maître confirmer face à
une grosse faute déjà joué par un homme
donc c'est une faute que vous pourrez
trouver un point donc intéressant de
cette variante parce que déjà les pauses
des petits pièges intéressante dans les
pièges de connaître ses pièces dans
cette variante ce sont des pièces qui
sont récurrents ou encore valdes
ouverture dont il faut apprendre à
connaître ce qu'il veut à savoir ce
qu'il faut faire quand la colonne eux
sauf complètement les dangers qui sont
relatifs à la faiblesse du roi bien sûr
alors qu'avant il prend ses 3 ou avancés
à l'écran célèbre des princes et rois
dépensé français voilà en fait regarder
la position de lancer simple on a ouvert
évidemment on appris en c3 évidemment
qu'on a éloigné un pion du centre alors
simplement on a aussi ouvert tout de
suite la voie pour un fou les blancs ont
choisi un développement rapide rapide
voilà ils veulent sortir les fous bouger
la dame faire le grand roque soit dit en
passant on voit que le plan c 3 va aider
à la solidité du grand rond oui alors
évidemment un grand roque avec ses
structures de pioncer quasiment il
attaque un petit point du béton dans
quasiment impossible d'attaquer du côté
noir
donc ils n'auront pas de problèmes de
défense les blancs il va falloir par
contre qu'ils soient extrêmement
dynamique pour pas que cette structure
leur soit défavorable
plus loin dans la partie par exemple en
finale voilà donc un petit peu
défavorable
un petit peu défavorable donc après
dépensé 3 mais on va voir la suite du
développement un fou et c'est faux cette
classique ou trois très vite pour le
grand roque petit rock dam des deux
dames d2 on va simplement ouvrir ça y
est la ligne pour le rang qui si donc
qu'à blida et 17,5 ou un but surprenant
mais en fait l'idée des noirs c'est
qu'il voudrait ce cavalier hayes
s'échangent et peut-être contre le
contre le cavaliere 3 voulait changer à
la cavayère
et si tout ça n'était pas de mémoire
manque d espace qu'est ce qu'ils veulent
faire
ils veulent commencer à échanger des
pièces bien sûr c'est classique pour
l'instant ils n'ont pas trop d'espacé
effectivement grand roque
voilà la saga mais le salon propose un
échange
deux cavaliers alors à noter que quand
même que effectivement si noir tu ta
reprennent ce cas relief 3 après chypre
en f3 on a une belle colonie ouverte
contre le requin exact c'est intéressant
de laisser cavaliers ici pour que pour
inciter un peu des noirs à prendre et ça
oblige à une colonne j'ai ma foi fort
intéressante pour attaquer le rôle ainsi
vous voyez que la diatribe de la
structure si vous alliez l'adversaire a
vu une erreur à faire laisser leurs
affaires les cellules à faire voilà mais
sinon je ne passait jamais votre tour
pour attendre qu'ils la fassent dans un
second temps parfois passé son tour mais
bon faut laisser lui la possibilité de
la faire en vendée qu il voit là un
exactement journée comme ultime set donc
et la halle et blanc joue un coup bas
maintenant c'est parti on a presque
cavalier ou 5 nous empêche plus ou moins
de développer le foot case blanche
alors on va attendre c'est pas grave
mais on peut pas sortir se fout il va y
avait pendant trois jours il faut sortir
toutes les pièces mineurs mais encore
une épreuve à sortir ne l'est pas encore
on peut faire une exception des fans on
peut attendre un petit peu de trouver
vraiment une case convaincante bien sur
le fond en f1 n'est pas un fou enterré
pourra sentir quand il voudra jouer dans
vos petits mots vous filles et
commençons le plan du milieu de jeu
placer pour le recomposer h4 on lance
les pions h4 qui est un point de soutien
pour les pièces angers sens voilà
surtout pas pour jouer h 5 h si ce qui
serait tout simplement phare est la
terreur par g6 donc fermé la colonne
mais pour avant un poste avancé
voilà un pour out il un bon petit
soutien voilà donc h4 alors assurage 4
il faut que les noirs se développe aussi
lui donc
alors est-ce qu'on coup comme fou j'ai
quatre seraient envisagées n'ont pas
trop parce que alors le problème quand
on développe le fou un g4 dans ce genre
de deux parties c'est que finalement il
sert plus de deux cibles que deux
défenseurs mais parce qu'on va plus tard
essayer de jouer trois ou quatre on va
peut-être pouvoir s'en prendre à lui
effectivement donc c'est toujours un
petit peu risqué 1
on peut mettre le fou en deux dans un
premier temps et quand lecavalier sera
sera parti 2 ensuite on ajouter les 4
et ben si le fou s'échangeant 2 d'un
produit à 400 kg de riz intéressante
pour le cavalier d'interview
c'est pas si c'est pas évident de jouer
au foot et 4g clac c'est rare dans cette
variante voilà faut parce qu'on donne
une une pièce du côté où on veut
attaquer donc après tous les mouvements
de pions dont gagner de la force en
attaquant ses pièces voilà aussi alors
appris h4 alors donc les noirs peuvent
essayer de se développer en même temps
le beci franchetto avec le côté avec b
ci soit ici un nancy joue aussi il faut
17 on pourra peut-être joué cavalier des
quatre califes 5 ça peut être une idée
ou si oui la disparition du fou ça
déménage ses 8 h 3 et peut être
problématique
c'est un peu ce qui se passe avec
cavaliers les 4 x y est fou bessette
donc fou quand même bien placé
évidemment si ça empêche le coup au g4
évident tout de suite à cause de la
tourache 1 alors
mais c'est un fou qui protège plus trop
les loin quand même là j'ai beaucoup
aimé le jeu danone parce qu'on n'a pour
l'heure pas encore dit mais on s'est
appuyé sur une partie d'année encore une
fois contre le sun elle gagne alexeyev
qui l'ancien champion de russie voilà
qui est un jeune extrêmement prometteur
delà de la nouvelle russie je dirais et
bien moi j'ai beaucoup aimé le jeu vous
attendent dans cette partie et là il
joue fou g5 voilà alors avec un échange
angers 5
on comprend bien que les blancs sont
quand même bien et sérieusement
augmenter la pression sur l'accolade
alors si on prend du plomb h évident
surtout prends tu en prends du clown
voyez tout de suite la tour qui devient
très actif sur le pion h7
on va vite que peut y avoir une attaque
de matelas vraiment rapide car
évidemment on est noir on pas prendre
angers 5
mais qu'est ce que va faire un an débat
il va forcer les noirs a prononcé cinq
comment on fait pour forcer une pièce à
prendre et bien en mettant la pression
dessus car il y avait cinq des petites
choses comme ça et
on va voir que si le foot reste en scène
tôt ou tard il aurait fallu qu'ils
s'échangent danger sans voix la foulée
500f 6.6 d'un mètre carré mais la
création ouais mais la pression sur le
foulard là on est on est sorti de la
théorie un sens et une partie des
amendes mais cette partie d'un monde
exprime bien ce qu'il faut faire dans le
voilà c'est pour montrer leur proposer
tout simplement voilà trois jours c'est
ça c'est ça l'idée maîtresse de cette
ouverture camera 3 le roc opposés et
donc on montre comment monter une
attaque de recomposer dans cette
situation là dans cette position là avec
ce plan h4 considérer que l'ouverture
est terminée quand on a sorti des pièces
et maintenant on montre un plan typique
voilà un exemple cavaler g6 d'un médecin
qu'on garde la pression évidemment sur
les eaux menacent de faire vous prendrez
eu 6 400 la structure du rock et bien
sûr donc là c'est l'heure pour prendre
en charge des jeux prend et on voit bien
tout de suite je crois qu'on peut
arrêter là même jean baptiste et on a
une belle colonie ouvertes les
possibilités de jouer un match trois
dames prend h7 avait des échecs on peut
sortir lorsqu'on peut s'arrêter là on a
déjà suffisamment de munitions pour agir
pour avoir une bonne partie on a le
front en d3 qui peut arriver vite là il
faut très vite que les noirs jo tour
huit cavaliers fuite pendant dans sa
cellule va falloir jouer évidemment tour
huit cavaliers fuite pour les protéger
sa set cette mauvaise position
on va vite que le cas les d4 aussi quand
la dame aura bougé pourra sauter un f5 à
une très belle case aussi donc un jeu
facile
je pense que vous avez une belle base de
données ou pourrait finir de la regarde
et vous verrez qu'à nantes n'a pas gagné
cette partie il a fait match nul blanc
tout car on a beaucoup aimé nous cette
façon qu'a eu un temps de traiter la
petrov tu as fait pour sortir un peu de
l'ordinaire de cette position mais terne
un peu terne que d'habitude tout à fait
alors
on a fait toujours prendre sur le sur
l'ensemble de ses demandes
qu'est-ce qu'on va retenir donc
évidemment c'est bon mais le thème
évident là petrov c'est ce coup
cavaliers prend le cinq des six est ici
donc alors on a vu la variante cabaye
prend f7 on vient on a vu au début
j'avais donc cette idée cette idée
générale qui est de jouer le simple
cavale et c3 alors attendez ça a été
jouée par presque tous les taux les
beaux jours de quatre ans voilà un
moment donné on avait tous marre ils ont
tous mis à zurich a essayé trois l'écho
l'écho à grande
bronzé vite tout le monde est donc la
variante a été popularisé assez
rapidement et on a beaucoup de beaucoup
de bases maintenant pour avoir quelques
idées dans cette partie et même si la
théorie ne donne pas un avantage
écrasant aux blancs on veut des idées
simples je suis partie d'échecs
ça c'est une idée simple développement
rapide rock recomposée et après et on
balance et on sait quoi faire on balance
la paix en balance les entrées bondir de
4 c'est parfait c'est parfait c'est donc
une bonne arme pour la petrov des
variantes récente aussi jouer au plus
haut niveau y compris quelques pièges
qu'on a vu tout un piège très
sympathique sur cette barre de cavalli
c3 donc on vous invite à mettre à votre
répertoire évidemment suite à ces mêmes
en tout cas ça y est le voilà exactement
cette leçon voilà et puis qu'il faut
connaître avec les noirs si on joue la
paix tran huy voilà merci à l'historien
stéphane à bientôt et maintes fois